hey dave today's question comes from
sean in wyoming uh sean says i recently
graduated nursing school with 19
000 in student loan debt my girlfriend
and i want to get married next year the
hospital
where i will be working at pays 250
a month towards student loans i want to
pay more than that
and have my debt paid off by next year
do you think it is possible
or should i postpone my wedding
um you know dave i think here it's it's
two things one
i think yes you should take advantage of
the 250 a month and also add more to
that
uh but i am not me personally going to
tell you to wait to marry
the love of your life because you are in
debt agreed
you know um i would definitely say do
what you can
um as far as whatever you can afford but
then at the same time i want you to go
ahead and pay
cash for the wedding and so if that
means you gotta pause a little bit just
to set aside five grand for the wedding
and then jump back in
on it i'm totally with that but don't
postpone
the love of your life because of because
of your debt
but i do want you to attack attack it as
much as you possibly can
okay what we don't know from his
question is who's paying for the wedding
whether he is or not he just says we
want to get married next year right
my hospital where i'll be working will
pay 250 a month which is three thousand
dollars in one year
yep um i want to pay more
and have everything paid off so here's
the thing sean
you're just out of school uh you're been
living like a college student i want you
to keep living
like a college student and the great
news
about the nursing field is that you can
work
all you wanna work
and so uh but while you're planning the
wedding
um you already got her on the hook
because you're engaged
so you can just work like all the time
like that policeman just did yep an hour
you know 80 hours a week
and he paid off 192 000 in three years
now she was working too in that case
right but uh i bet you can knock out the
19 especially if they're going to give
you three so you only got to knock out
16
in one year and still get married yes
all i'm saying is keep your lifestyle to
nothing
scorched earth syndrome beans and rice
rice and beans
and work like a freaking maniac yes
that's where money comes from and the
great news about nursing is you can
always work always take those weekend
shifts at the er
they pay big do some uncomfortable stuff
and be done with this a hundred percent
done with it you're completely
out of that and clean when you get
married that would be a whole different
way to get married
now we're not saying post upon the
wedding we're just saying work your butt
off
and i would have told you that if you
were married too by the way and i would
have told you that if you were single
and dating by
the way so the whole answer is you make
more money by working more
and keep your lifestyle to nothing by
the way the good news about working all
the time is
you ain't got time to spend money you
know even today do you know when i spend
the most money when i'm bored
oh yeah that's when people start
clicking on that little prime button
that's true on amazon i think i need one
of those i'm not sure what it is but i
need one of those
i'm going to look up crap and make up
something that i don't even know i need
and get me one
right that's what happens when you're
bored but when you're working all the
time and you're
you know when you're all all you when
you come home all you got to do is fall
asleep because you've been working
because you're tired
yeah i wouldn't want to be a workaholic
listen that's not a danger for most
people in our culture
right most people don't work enough
and they don't work while they're at
work there's an idea
you know and all that i mean so you know
just just and let me tell you you're not
gonna die from overwork just before you
die you'll pass out
yeah it's okay so i mean you're gonna be
all right you're not gonna die from
overwork and i'm not suggesting you do
this the rest of your life i'm
suggesting you do it for a very short
time it's a sprint
so that you never have to do it again
you're retraining your whole life
so good dave that's good i mean like you
know we do the same thing around here
even and it's not about making money but
it's about getting momentum to something
like
like when you launch a book yes there's
like a big pile of work right there it's
called a book tour
all the media hits 16 freaking hour days
yes i mean
and they also they all look like it's
like a groundhog day because you answer
the same question over and over and over
about the same book right
and it's just but you have to be
mentally on emotionally on spiritually
on physically on
because you get fatigued because you're
working your butt off but it's you don't
we don't do that
we don't work we won't work each other
like that oh i don't work like that all
the time
no but i can when i need to to get to a
goal and the reward
the sprint yes and the reward is so
refreshing afterwards
the momentum that you get off of it yes
you can spin something up in your life
that
that spirals out there another decade
from a 90-day or 120-day sprint
yeah and that's what we do when we
launch a book it's what you do when you
get rid of debt
it's the same kind of stuff